oh yeah oh yeah yeah that story i
actually my friends and i
cosplayed at comic hit like six years
ago and we were like
the top trending thing at that time on
on 2chan saying these three american
girls cosplaying as love live on the
train
and shame on me for not doing my
research right right hand
but but still chill yeah i had like
friends in america japanese friends in
america messaged me what are you guys
doing over there
you can't cosplay on the train wait it's
not even fun though i'd love to see your
cosplay on there we had like a minute
in circle follow us from station to
station
they were like oh can you take that off
but we were only wearing the wig we were
wearing like i was wearing normal
clothes just the wigs
you don't even allow to wear a wig yeah
that's weird and then i told well
my friend told he's like you know we're
only wearing the wig and like no they
know from your hair
what character you are but like i
understand if it's something you know
like
gratuitous like if you were all
cosplaying as like [ __ ] you know
ryuko right yeah it's like you know
where it's like a little more like yeah
yeah like yeah like a little more like
scandalous right like it's love live
you're in school uniform yeah
the only thing that separates you from
like a regular school girl is just the
wig
yeah but to be fair like they want to
protect this culture they want to keep
having these events
they're not it's just gay kids
that is gay because like for example
normie would be on the train and they
see
some crazy isn't that fun though yeah
but they
made your life up a little bit but also
like anime otakus in japan aren't viewed
in like a positive
like i don't think they necessarily all
they're in the west
i don't i don't feel like there's as bad
as stigma compared to this here
because i think you're like sweaty and
i mean i am but like
we're all swiping you can't you're just
so weird you watch like the weird stuff
on the internet
my life's not even that weird i rocked
up on the london underground
in the maid outfit like just did it just
like
40-minute commute hell yeah yeah
everyone loves it they're like all
laughing or giggling laughs but they
would be like what are you cosplaying or
dressing up as yeah i'd get like heckled
from the other side of the thing and
then like you know it's just good fun i
don't know i i thought it was funny but
obviously i guess
it's such a weird double standard though
isn't it where it's like you know like
anime loving otakus are like ew sweaty
gross and then meanwhile if there's a
guy rocking up with like full-on like
you know idol
[ __ ] and just like oh you just really
like idols it's like
it's like no he's just as sweaty like a
lot of people think it's gross like
every time i told like japanese people
like
like oh i'm i'm in otaku they're like no
you're not you don't look like a what is
it
and it's like really like how dare you
insult my people
yeah yeah yeah like what's what's what
are they expecting otaku to look like
where it's like you're [ __ ] 300
pounds yeah
i think it's like how weeaboo the word
weeaboo used to be
seen like 10 years ago in our community
where who
who would like identify themselves as a
weeaboo that's like cringy
cringy like that's like a cringy person
nobody wants to know right
right because because the stereotypical
like otaku in japan
like you don't see people like that
anymore no no there's like there's like
people who like anime and that's just
like normalized here
like 20 year old girls have like the ita
bags
yeah yeah yeah i love 2d boys and
everyone loves jojo's
everyone
that's like the chichi right you just
wear jojo merch to like a business
meeting
and everything feels so good yeah you'll
get like a 50 year old businessman can't
you be like i love jojo's
dude i was buying manga like my local
bookstore and i was wearing one of the
glam jojo shirts yeah the guy like
stopped like
putting in the books and he's like
where'd you get that shirt
and i was like oh glam and he's like
that looks sick dude he's just
high-fived me i'm like
i've never had this experience in japan
obviously this is before the pandemic
right social distance but like and
everyone claps everyone in the store
applauded joey
congratulations and then they played the
jojo opening and i left
dating in japan video i mentioned like
oh yeah i just openly said i was an
otaku and then i was like why are people
getting all worked up about it and then
i got loads of comments so like
it means a bad thing in japan and i was
like yeah i know i just don't care like
yeah if i can normalize it i can help to
get there
yeah if someone wasn't seeing a negative
light that's their prerogative exactly
yeah most most of the people that i told
you didn't give a [ __ ] yeah